People came,
took the land of the Palestinians.
Every year they extend their occupation.
When you look at the map of Palestine,
there is nothing left of land in Palestine.
The people of Palestine have got nothing to lose
but their chains.
They must stand up and fight for their freedom.
And condemning Hamas is an act of paradise.
The war in Palestine is not a holy war,
is an evil war.
Because even here,
the apartheid African regime used to say
they are the chosen ones,
used to say they are children of god
and we are animals.
So when the minister of defence of Israel
calls Palestinians animals,
we know what it means
because we were called animals ourselves
here in South Africa
by those who were claiming they were signed by god.
There is no holy war there.
There is an evil war.
And we must always stand against the evil.